machine voyez cette jambe sur à 10
millions je me doute bien que c'est pas
le cerveau qui est assurée
on va se mettre sur les places
handicapées mais tu sais qui je suis moi
je vois que si mme bullock a enchanté
moi céramique auriel pense que tu es
fini merci anglais autre info pour un
truc pour redorer son image
un retour aux sources mais oui tu va
repartir dans le berry mais bien sûr à
la ferme chez mon père tu vois bien que
c'est crosland ici et des ploucs
elle est magnifique ça veut dire quoi
rosenau des pink eux pour qu'ils veulent
accueillir
mais non ces crises au sucre et sociale
est vraiment devenu un coup c'est vous
il veut bien que maxime reste mais il ya
une condition que maxime après midi
ajoute voilà sur une jambe un boris
havas avait pas la france
vous les pontons de la pelouse ou quoi
qu'es-tu poulina qui dorment là les
plots classe lève tôt tiendrait pas deux
jours pas mal tu sais faire la même
chose sur un terrain tu as ta place dans
mon équipe fonctionne par là
au journal elle est pas la jolie enfin à
l'autre aujourd'hui c'est la grosse qui
va s'occuper de toi mon mignon déjà
incroyable j'avais perdu un fils et tu
découvres plus que c'est un anniversaire
bon bah nous alors arrête donc parce que
je suis black marvel mamadou tu vois ce
que je veux dire je suis désolé vous
comment tu t'appelles